today's question comes from Alice in
Washington she visits Dave Ramsey comm
to ask how do I approach my broke
roommate about her tardiness in paying
her half of the bills directly and often
and bluntly we sit down we turn off the
television and we have a direct very
firm but kind calm conversation this
roommate thing is not working it's not
working because you're not paying your
bills on time try every dollar dot-com
download it to your it's a free
budgeting app for your iPhone or your
Android roommate and when you put that
on there in about ten minutes you'll
have a budget because you and I are not
going to be able to stay here together
anymore if you don't start paying on
time you are straining our relationship
and you are taking advantage of it and I
am through with this really Alice you're
being too nice and you think by being
subtle or being nice that you're really
being nice and you're not you're just
being passive-aggressive to be unclear
is to be unkind darling be very clear
you don't have to be mean you don't cuss
and scream and throw things that's not
what I'm talking about
you just smile and say this is not going
to happen any more you are going to get
your act together and you're going to
pay on time it's called adulting we are
going to do this together on time baby
doll really I mean it's not hard you
know I'm amazed I had to learn that as a
leader running this organization I guess
600 folks working here and the same kind
of thing happens with team members I'm
from the south and you know we're
supposed to smile be nice to you and say
bless your heart while we slit your
throat right and so I mean like it's
like called good manners or something
and that's just a bunch of crap and so I
thought by being nice to people who were
misbehaving inside the organization that
I was being nice to them but ultimately
me and everybody else in the
organization became frustrated with them
and they ended up getting their butt
fired and that's not really being nice
to somebody it's much a nicer to
somebody to communicate
early in the process that their behavior
is out of line and give them the
opportunity to adjust their behavior
while they can stay in the organization
or we can stay in this relationship and
that's much kinder really
and so I'm unbelievably blunt now and
quick really quick on the draw like
instantaneous you really do know exactly
where you stand can you imagine that
with me I'm now way with everybody too
and I'm not mad about it I'm it's not me
being angry and I'm not your anger base
no I'm not I'm just not gonna we just
are not going to wait until I am angry
with your misbehavior and then you react
poorly and I used to do that and I don't
do that anymore I almost never get angry
in these situations anymore and if I do
I'll wait to deal with the situation
until I'm not angry anymore I just
because I want to sit there and just be
kind and calm but give you very very
clear guidelines of the behaviors that
are going to occur in order for us to
continue in this relationship in your
case it's a roommate in my case it might
be a team member here but it could be
anything in the book you know that
that's just being kind it's kind it's
tough love no it's just love you want to
call it tough you know you know it's not
tough it's just being kind you just tell
people where they stand and that's how
you handle it very very cool a good
question and had that one in a while
good roommate question oh by the way
help you guys that are setting up
roommates because a lot of you are like
this time of year you're going back to
school after the holidays with an uber
set of roommates or you're thinking
about moving out and getting a roommate
or whatever you're doing let me tell you
how to handle that on the the roommate
deal is you handle all this on the front
end you have a little meeting a little
formal meeting and you could even like
write up house rules you know and just
everybody sign them and it's not like
we're doing a contract it's just clear
communication upfront here's what we're
going to do we're going to do this and
we're going to do this and we're going
to do this and you know we're not going
to do this and we're not going to do
this or you know we're not gonna do
cocaine in the house you know this count
you just have to write some it's down
for some of these people right and you
just have a clear
understanding upfront and then no one's
like well I didn't know it's going to be
that no we all talked about it up front
and I'll tell you another place I used
to do that the pre-emptive meeting I did
we do it with tenants or mavin a tenant
move into our property we say this is
how it's gonna work you paint you get to
stay you don't pay you don't get to stay
you call us when something breaks we
come fix it it's a pretty cool
arrangement it's called being a tenant
but you don't pay don't be shocked we
will move you quickly like
instantaneously out of the property it
won't happen and and by the way no you
can't have a cat and no you can have a
dog and if you get one then you will
move or the dog or cat will move and you
know it's real simple we talked about
this up front and then nobody's you mean
I can't have a pet no we told you up
front you can't have a pet because you
know when you have a rental property
near the landlord let me tell you what a
cat costs you ten grand because you
can't get cat pee smell out of a house
it's impossible so you know we just
don't have cats we don't do it period
don't like I mean I love them I love
dogs I like cats but I love dogs
and so but you're not gonna have a dog
in the house so you just talked about it
up front right we did this while I was
coaching my son's ice hockey team you
ever coached one of those little league
teams good lord
have you ever been in that situation
really you you donate your time to put
up with psychotic parents you ever done
that the only thing worse than coaching
it is reffing Little League sports where
people will strangle your wife because
you didn't get a call for their
eight-year-old at the soccer game it's
unbelievable man so we just had a little
discussion and ice hockey's worse
because it's violent you know so the
parents are violent everybody's violence
rednecks you know it's unbelievable with
a stick you know so we're just we gather
up have a little parent's meeting I'm
like guys I'm doing this to be spend
time with my son and last time I checked
there's no pay so any of you want to
volunteer and do it you can do it but I
got a rule or two here's the rule you
don't talk about me and how about a
coach I am to your kid all the way home
and then scratch your head and wonder
why I can't coach your kid because
you're undercutting me
the whole time and I promise if you all
talk about me I won't talk about how
stupid you are to your kid and we'll
just have a little agreement right here
and we talked you know we had great
parents every year but one year
I mean I coach for like eight years I
had the best parents in the world on my
team everybody's like your parents all
get along we set the rules on the front
end we laid out what the relationship
was going to be and what it was not
going to be on the front end and then no
one was shocked but sometimes you just
got to say stuff out loud to people and
you do that with your roommate going in
that's you you can handle a lot of stuff
with roommates if you do it on the front
end and tardy paying is not okay
that's just it's just not okay it's a
sign other crêpes going on in their life
and you know here's the thing it's not
gonna get better until it gets better
meaning that it's not gonna just
accidentally get better you're gonna
have to talk down and again I would
you're going to feel like you're not
that you're being too blunt and you're
just barely being blunt enough for them
to hear you at that point so you have to
be very crystal clear but again low
voice not yelling when I'm being smart
out of nothing you know acerbic and our
approach to this low voice kind smile
but very firm hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
Oh